welcome to this video yet playing bright
Holt bright hot in this zone five minute
game I'm trying something new the modern
defense oh okay yeah probably with e
five yeah knew not new in terms of
totally unexplored stuff but neway
channels of then I'm not playing it at
all so he's doing the Queen trade which
I don't mind can put this King 1c7 here
and there should be should be fine I
wonder now he's got maybe your butcher
coming to see five young yeah I should
cover that first bishop h6e he's got
tonight exit five so i will cover that
and i want i really want to be ripe age
6 m to trade higher okay so he's trying
to get the bishop on c4 which is a good
idea still should I play this or not and
I still think I should trade Bishop
takes Knight takes that I've got 94 as a
little threat so he probably has to
spend a move to prevent that probably I
kept a rookie to know he does not need
to play age three can play something
like that so now King e7 yeah I guess
let's let's take c 5 a-5 for the a
failure
v5
yeah I guess opening up the house should
be something that helps me a little bit
oops okay that was a message hmm so okay
planned straight i wonder if i should
play b6 here actually to totally open it
up
mb6 ma might be maybe even rock t-6s a
move then but I ok 6 is not not a fatal
move take my things yeah this is I think
probably okay for me but still not sure
how good this is but yeah takes Knight
takes if the bishop moves to be three I
can maybe just play Bishop e6 form for a
trade at least my king is participating
in the in the game 107 I still wander a
bit about would be six if this is a move
i also have okay one on that yeah this
should really should be okay really i
thought bishop is six now for the trade
Ian that that's good yep with the tempo
actually oh it's not taking that makes
sense of why should he take king be to
us also also on so I don't know if night
c4 is giving me anything I just play
with 96 I think this is a good idea I
move like Ruby t2 which looks totally
natural now runs into night to d6 with
94 threatened so this normal news is not
helping him okay so yeah maybe 996 SL
useful anyway 494 and he feels obliged
to cover that so like luke t 8 this is
any good maybe rock g8
yeah it's nothing special but probably I
don't have any big alternative and this
looks a bit weird the night on the two
is potentially hanging night to be five
Knight to f5 those kind of moves
and I to be five
isn't this good d 2 was hang with check
went down on one minute job every did
look at the clock okay check nice good
look at seven check this is this is a
bad thing I didn't think about that very
much time morning I wanted to take here
and take on g2 what is good look at 790
soon okay I have to be quick check
it's probably nothing special all right
you can give this can take here notes is
seven check this is definitely okay for
white I guess it's very active so check
out but I can go to e7 now then where's
the night going down okay h2s hanging up
or h4 for that matter yes night is
somewhat somewhat out of it can play
night c7 back threatened 98 but I will
still just take the pawns check you can
take here on f6 but I don't don't mind
that so much I think getting the f porn
check okay is getting this Jan not good
okay
I should push my pants as quickly as
possible here I difficult no fan Mia on
d5 just not a great place for the rook
now I'm promoting right I'm promoting
here John this is this is enough check
check got 12 seconds buddy I'm manage
check checkmate okay wow so on yeah
around here this was a little bit
uncomfortable for white it's just a
little bit more active him but I think
here 95 was really a really good now
yeah blackest is winning now ya hear oh
I had a much better move here look a
Judy ate as much stronger and
threatening checkmate hui yeah that's
great yeah it's very strong black wins
out outrider right justice justice trick
media when you can you can do stuff like
that and then then play stuff it's stuff
like this but it's still a win now this
kind of thing check and black wins
easily this is Sir yeah just just just
by materialia to pieces and upon plus a
good position Windsor quite easily okay
but what I did shape in an advantage but
not enough probably I are here take
station check
drew a six is better now okay look a six
mmhmm yeah that's better i am if i take
now here this is the key point check
check do this and now I mean the problem
yeah how to to ever get anything going
this night is dominating my night and
this seems to be a draw if you have the
comp which you probably can do in this
position yeah I'm even risking stings
King b5 rookie 6 yeah yeah let's all day
I mean he's very active so but the way
it was played here after King d6 now I'm
winning out the arm straight straight
winning check that probably wasn't
perfect but I had too little time check
now it seems that he can draw now with
good play rookie 6 no this is wrong yeah
rookie 6 immediately seems to draw I ok
the idea is that check and King b5 his
is a problem and I can do here I can go
here and then then draw I mean of those
two points yeah so drawing is ok and
easy for black but I cannot win which
probably is not the case here i am.here
black wins ok yeah well thanks for
watching